Hey there, smartless listeners, Conan O'Brien here. Wanted to let you know I recently had your very own Jason Bateman on my podcast, Conan O'Brien Needs a Friend, who talked about Jason's roots as a child star, his breakout role on Arrest Development, and of course his fellow smartless co-host, Sean and Will. Here's a little taste of what we got up to. You know, the question is, are you Conan O'Brien's friend if you aren't invited to his Christmas party? And you know, there's so many hundreds of Conan O'Brien's friend if you aren't invited to his Christmas party? And you know, there's so many hundreds
嘿，SmartLess的听众们，我是柯南·奥布莱恩。想告诉大家，我最近在我的播客《柯南·奥布莱恩需要一个朋友》中邀请了你们的杰森·贝特曼。我们聊到了杰森作为童星的出身、他在《发展受阻》中的突破性角色，当然还有他SmartLess的搭档肖恩和威尔。以下是我们聊天内容的一小段片段。你知道，问题是，如果你没被邀请参加柯南·奥布莱恩的圣诞派对，你还算他的朋友吗？而且你知道，有成百上千个...
and hundreds of people. We've straightened this out. No, thousands are invited to the Christmas party. I invite thousands and about 50 come. Listen, we're gonna just, cause this has been a thing and then I went on SmartList recently, you know, about you coming to the Christmas party
成百上千的人。我们已经澄清过了。不，有几千人受邀参加圣诞派对。我邀请了成千上万的人，但大约只有50人会来。听着，我们只是，因为这已经成了一个梗，然后我最近上了《SmartLess》，你知道，关于你来参加圣诞派对的事
and it was a thing for a while. You claim you weren't invited. I was shocked that there was the Christmas party. And it was a thing for a while. You claim you weren't invited. I was shocked that there was a Christmas party. That the Christmas party had been going on for years. But you were, I think you were shocked that Christmas was celebrated. Because you're such a cringe. That Christmas had something to do
这事儿闹了一阵子。你声称你没被邀请。我很震惊竟然还有圣诞派对这回事。而且这事儿闹了一阵子。你声称你没被邀请。我很震惊竟然还有圣诞派对。圣诞派对已经举办好几年了。但我认为你震惊的是圣诞节竟然还在庆祝。因为你太尴尬了。圣诞节竟然和...
with your Lord and Savior, Jesus Christ. I was like. Well, listen, the point is you, you know, let's talk about smart lists. It's a juggernaut. You guys are. It's a pretty hard pivot. It's a real, I mean, I was a four wheel slide. Can I say something?
你的主和救世主耶稣基督有关。我当时就想。好吧，听着，重点是你，你知道，我们来聊聊《SmartLess》。它简直是个巨无霸。你们这些家伙。这转折太生硬了。真的，我的意思是，我当时就像四轮打滑一样。我能说点什么吗？
Right? I just broke my hip pivoting. But no, the point I'm trying to make is of you three guys, you got Will Arnett, you got Sean, is it Hayes? Yeah, I think it's H-A-Z-E. Okay. And then you're Jason.
对吧？我刚才转弯时差点把胯骨摔断了。但不是，我想表达的重点是，你们三个人里，有威尔·阿奈特，有肖恩，是叫海耶斯吗？对，我想是H-A-Z-E。好的。然后你是杰森。
Bateman. Bateman. Okay, there's the three of you, and you're the one that I have trouble getting a beat on. I gotta say, you're the one, you're squirrely. You're squirrely, Bateman. I've always had a problem getting a beat on. I gotta say, you're the one, you're squirrely. You're squirrely, Bateman. I've always had a problem getting a beat on you. A huge fan of yours. I adore you, but I can't get a beat on the guy.
贝特曼。贝特曼。好的，你们三个，而你是我最摸不透的那一个。我得说，你是那个，你很滑头。你很滑头，贝特曼。我一直很难摸透你。我是你的超级粉丝。我崇拜你，但我就是摸不透这个人。
I can't. Because you can sense that I'm not sure why I'm there. And I don't really, I'm not really sure if I, I don't get it. I don't understand why people listen to it. I get that Will and Sean are appealing fellas. That's why they're two of my best friends. And we're not doing anything more than just the drivel
我做不到。因为你能感觉到我不知道自己为什么在那儿。我真的，我不太确定我是否，我不明白。我不明白为什么人们会听这个。我明白威尔和肖恩是很有魅力的人。这就是为什么他们是我最好的两个朋友。我们做的不过就是些废话
that happens when we're in a car together or at a dinner. I just don't think that that's monetizable. That you should ask for people's attention to listen to that. That you can monetizable. That you should ask for people's attention to listen to that. That you can monetize. I agree with it about your podcast. I agree, because I've checked it out. And I'm like, I can't believe that this is something,
当我们一起在车里或吃饭时发生的那些。我只是觉得那不具备商业价值。你不应该要求人们花时间去听那些。那你可以商业化。我同意你关于你播客的看法。我同意，因为我听过。我当时想，我简直不敢相信这是真的，
I mean, this, what we're doing here. You've got a full, you've got an array of talent here. And you've probably done some- Hold on a second, let me put my glasses on. She's really disagree with that. You've done some- Hold on a second, let me put my glasses on. Jesus, really? Even we disagree with that. You've done some prep, right? I can see questions there.
我的意思是，我们在这里做的这些。你这里有一群，你有一整套人才。你可能做了一些——等一下，让我戴上眼镜。她真的不同意这一点。你做了一些——等一下，让我戴上眼镜。天哪，真的吗？连我们都不同意这一点。你做了一些准备，对吧？我能看到那儿有提问稿。
No, no, no, this is your medical history. Oh. This is your medical history. You've got a handsome studio, you've got cameras around. This is very professional. Yeah, also- We're on a Zoom. Also, can I just point out,
不，不，不，这是你的病史。哦。这是你的病史。你有一个很棒的工作室，周围有摄像机。这非常专业。是的，还有——我们在用Zoom。还有，我能指出吗，
I've been interviewing people around the clock since 1993. I'm a seasoned professional on what Muhammad Ali was to boxing I am to interviewing. We can cut all this off. You need lifts. Yeah. Yeah. But you guys with this, you know, R&N.
我从1993年起就一直在采访各种人。我是个经验丰富的专业人士，穆罕默德·阿里对拳击意味着什么，我对采访就意味着什么。我们可以把这些都剪掉。你需要升降台。是的。是的。但你们这些家伙，你知道，R&N。
But in, yes, but at least Will, at least Will has just sharp dagger humor. He's got a darkness that's fun to follow. A voice that's not bad to listen to. No, I buy whatever truck he's selling. Right? Yeah. I mean, as long as it's professional grade.
但是，是的，但至少威尔，至少威尔有那种尖锐的讽刺幽默。他有一种有趣的黑暗面。声音听起来也不错。不，他卖什么我都买账。对吧？是的。我的意思是，只要是专业级别的。
He's got an opinion and he'll let you know it. Sean P. Hayes is sure is just pure sunshine and is curious and is warm. And I'm trying to find the lane that I'm supposed to be in which is the area in between those two which I guess is just sort of listening and asking questions that I think the normal guy wants to know. You know?
他有自己的观点，而且会让你知道。肖恩·P·海耶斯绝对是纯粹的阳光，充满好奇心，而且很温暖。我正在努力寻找我应该处于的位置，也就是介于他们两人之间的那个区域，我想那大概就是倾听，并提出我认为普通人想知道的问题。你知道吗？
And so I feel I'm easily replaceable. Yes, yes, I was gonna say the same thing. I was gonna say, I'm glad you said it. I beat you. No, no, no, I think you could come, you could go, you know, whatever. Which is kind of what I do and whatever the hell I do on camera too.
所以我感觉我很容易被取代。是的，是的，我正想说同样的话。我正想说，很高兴你说了出来。我比你先说。不，不，不，我觉得你可以来，你可以走，你知道，随你便。这其实也是我在镜头前所做的事情。
I'm trying to just kind of be us. To hear the rest of the episode, as well as other great conversations I've had with folks like Amy Poehler, Adam Scott, Ben Stiller, and more, check out Conan O'Brien Needs a Friend, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我只是试着做回自己。想要收听本集的其余部分，以及我与艾米·波勒、亚当·斯科特、本·斯蒂勒等人的其他精彩对话，请在任何你获取播客的地方收听《柯南·奥布莱恩需要一个朋友》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。